brianna kupfer was a graduate student at
ucla studying architectural design i say
was
because she's dead
dead at the age of 24 killed while
simply working at a furniture store
trying to put herself through school
killed by a man accused of crimes that
literally spanned the country from
charleston south carolina to los angeles
california
he was out on bond accused of shooting
into a car in south carolina but the
authorities in california didn't notify
law enforcement in south carolina when
he was recently arrested
they just released him
and he killed a 24 year old just trying
to work her way through
school
rachel dowden was waiting at a bus stop
in pennsylvania waiting to go home after
a long day at work
and she was shot and killed by a man
ordered by the court to stay away from
her
court orders are no match
for a bullet
michelle go was waiting on the subway in
new york city she was pushed in front of
a train by a man with a long criminal
history
and mental health issues
she's dead
killed by a man who should have been in
jail or a mental hospital tesla majors
was a college student in new york she
was an aspiring musician she
was
because she's dead too
killed by teenagers over a cell phone
the prosecutor in her case noted the
obvious during a court hearing when he
said tessa is gone for good
gone from the earth for good no more
music no more school no more anything
and if you're wondering what the state
of new york thinks her life was worth
the answer
is 14 years 14 years is what the person
who killed her
received it's hard to read about these
cases and what happened to these women
no matter how long you have worked in
the justice system it is hard and
painful to see beautiful
vibrant lives ended by people who should
never have been in a position to hurt or
kill others
and when you read stories about these
four
women you will see words like
compassionate and loving and kind and
caring and angelic and hard-working
and now all four are dead
and i wonder where the outrage is
i see politicians getting upset about
all manner of things but where is the
outrage over the only thing that really
matters
which is your right to live
it's one thing to acknowledge this
country is in the throes of a violent
crime surge there are plenty of
statistics to back that up
these women however are not numbers
these women and others like them are not
columns on an fbi crime index
they were daughters and sisters and
wives and mothers and friends and
coworkers
i took note of a phrase president biden
repeated during his press conference
this week he said americans want three
squares and to be safe in fact
he said it twice
americans want to be safe
it's more than just want to be safe mr
president americans have the right to be
safe because there is no liberty there
is no pursuit of happiness without
life
you can't vote if you're dead you can't
sign up for a government program if
you're dead you can't build back better
if you're dead
so what is he doing about it there are
elements within his party who want more
violent people out on bond more charges
dropped more light sentences there are
elements within his party who actually
blame the police for the rising violent
crime there are elements of his party
who literally advocate for the closing
of prisons
biden gets very animated talking about
what he believes are voting rights and
challenging and changing the rules of
the senate
what about changing the rules so there
are fewer victims so the innocent public
is better protected what about making
sure you can work in a store without
being killed or wait on a bus or stand
on a subway platform or just walk home
in new york
these four young women and scores more
like them
have forever lost the right to vote
or do anything else
the right to live is the most
fundamental right you have
and i wonder when president biden is
going to get upset about that
and when will the media ask him about
that i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilmeade
and i'm ainsley earhardt and click here
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis